a couple of weeks ago I got into some
trouble with some online leftists who
for some reason watched my show
obsessively like Joy Behar they were
Furious that um I said something
everyone knows is true which is that the
primary problem facing homeless people
isn't the fact that they don't have
homes homelessness is instead a symptom
of many other problems that homeless
people have almost invariably including
drug addiction a general disinterest and
being productive members of society and
usually that this interest is fueled by
drug addiction or alcoholism or mental
illness
like all harsh truths that happen to be
undeniable you're not supposed to say
that out loud so in response a swarm of
leftists attacked
um and we're very upset about it it's a
theme here today on the show and in
every show really I'm going to play one
example of these attacks because it's
important to understand the reasoning
from the left on the topic of
homelessness such as it is and as just
one example I'll show you a clip from a
YouTube channel called secular talk now
there are two things you should know
about this clip before we play it first
of all he spends the first minute or two
of the video before the clip we're gonna
play explaining why my position on
homelessness uh does not comport with
the teachings of the Bible now he's
totally wrong about that of course the
Bible after all the Bible is the book
that says if a man will not work he
shall not eat you know it does not
recommend or condone a sedentary
self-destructive lifestyle
but putting that aside this guy's
Channel again is literally called
secular talk he's an atheist that's his
whole stick
and yet while totally rejecting the
Bible in every way he will still like
any other secular leftist try to use it
on occasion to win an argument which is
always funny to watch in a pathetic kind
of way the second thing you should know
is that the title of this video of his
says homeless people don't need homes
Matt Walsh the statement is put in
quotes quoting me as saying homeless
people don't need homes problem is I
never said that um he's making up a
quote and putting it in the title of the
video
so we're off to a bad start but anyway
here's the clip that helps set up our
discussion today let's watch so his
point is hey man it's not it's not that
they don't have uh the problem isn't
that the homeless people don't have
homes
uh they're uh they're drug addicts
they're drug addicts and they have
mental health problems that's his point
okay well let's look at the numbers on
this this is from Addiction Center
the National Coalition for the homeless
has found that 38 of homeless people are
alcohol dependent okay 38 now keep these
numbers in mind and I'm going to give
you the context for it in a second but
let's just point out 38 is actually not
a majority that's not a majority okay
more
26 percent are dependent on other
harmful chemicals okay so 26 are drug
addicts 38 are alcoholics okay got it
then they go on to say oftentimes
addiction is a result of homelessness in
other words he flipped the causation
what he's saying is you're an alcoholic
or you're a drug addict and that's why
you became homeless what they're saying
is no oftentimes the homelessness comes
first and then because you're homeless
you kind of want to take the edge off of
your harsh reality until you turn to
substances whether it be alcohol or
other kinds of drugs
so he flipped the causation now I'm sure
there are some instances where the
causation does work in the way that he
laid out there some people are
alcoholics or they are drug addicts and
then that helps as one of the factors to
lead them to become homeless but in many
instances maybe even more instances
maybe the majority of instances it's
first comes the homelessness and then in
order to take the edge off of your harsh
reality you turn to substances so that
you can survive
well that was that was great in order to
debunk my point uh he proves it now
first he's throwing out random
statistics that we're supposed to
believe on face value because they come
from a group with homeless in the title
he tells us nothing about where these
Stats come from how they were compiled
what the methodology was uh I you know
he just tells us well some group says
this like okay well what so
automatically I'm supposed to believe
that I mean if you actually believe that
only 26 percent of homes people are
using drugs if you really believe that
then you are simply too dumb to bother
having a conversation with and I just
don't I don't believe that anyone
believes really only 26 of homeless
people are on drugs
I mean it just happens like if you live
anywhere where you see homeless people
uh if you drive around see them in
Nashville
I can't remember the last time I saw
homeless people a homeless person that
wasn't obviously on drugs
but the funny thing is that even if we
buy these clearly absurdly under under
counted statistics my point still stands
we saw there in the screenshot that 38
of the homeless are alcoholics 26 are
addicted to Other Drugs that's already
64 which is a large majority
which is exactly what I said but then we
also see in the screenshot that he
didn't highlight
that's a 33 again according to these
stats that are obviously being very very
conservative in their estimates
but still 33 are mentally ill so 38 plus
26 plus 33.
and then you've got according to these
stats the the sum total of homeless
people who are addicts or mentally ill
well that's uh pretty much all of them
isn't it I'm no math whiz but that's
like all of them
even if we allow for some overlap in
these categories which obviously there's
going to be still it's clear that almost
all homeless people are either mentally
ill or on drugs or both
which again was exactly my point
but then we're told that actually I have
the causation flipped he insists that
homeless people first become homeless
presumably due to systemic racism or
economy the economy or whatever and then
to cope with their terrible situation
they turn to drug abuse
he has no evidence for this there's no
proof of it it's just nothing but his
own assumption
an assumption that does not comport with
basic common sense at all like what is
more likely that a totally functioning
and contributing member of society
somehow ends up homeless and then says
well I might as well smoke crack
or that a person starts smoking crack it
takes over their life
and soon they're on the street
now there may be cases of the former but
the latter is obviously the way this
usually works
there's no denying it and also no reason
to deny it
well maybe there is a reason for the
left the the appeal of this causation
argument is obvious
it absolves not just homeless people for
their conduct but also the politicians
who spend ever-growing amounts of
taxpayer money on so-called homelessness
initiatives after all if homeless people
are living good in virtuous lives and
only turn to drugs because they don't
have a roof over their heads then you
might think it's reasonable for large
states like California to spend forty
two thousand dollars per homeless person
every year you might not you might not
mind the the fact that by contrast
California spends less than fourteen
thousand dollars per year per student in
grades K through 12.
that disparity should bother you because
all of that spending on homelessness
reduction is simply encouraging
dysfunctional people to make the same
decisions that made them homeless in the
first place and we have a lot of real
observable case studies to prove this
not random statistics by some group that
you found on Google
like actual real world events we can
look at and see Ozil how did that work
out okay here's how it worked out
it turns out that when when you give a
homeless person a roof over his head
when you make them housed people instead
of unhoused people as left likes to say
they still resort to using drugs and
behaving dysfunctionally whether we love
it or hate it AI is here to stay AI is
expected to create over 100 million new
jobs globally some jobs include data
scientists product designers robotics
engineers and surprisingly tax managers
with AI skills supercriter is the best
way to use AI to help you find people
with these skills zippercruiters AI
identifies candidates who are best
suited for all kinds of roles right now
you can try for free at ziprecruiter.com
Walsh if you want the most qualified
candidates well ZipRecruiter uses its
powerful AI to find and send you people
whose skills and experience match your
job then ZipRecruiter lets you easily
invite them to apply to encourage them
to apply sooner in fact over 3.8 million
businesses have come to ZipRecruiter for
their hiring needs get the Leading Edge
on hiring with zip recruiter four out of
five employers who post on zipper
recruiter get a qualified candidate
within the first day see for yourself
how easy this is go this exclusive web
address to try ZipRecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
again that's ziprecruiter.com
w-a-l-s-h zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire take a look at this news report
this week out of Rutland County Vermont
this is one of the many places that's
decided to house homeless people in
hotels free of charge on the theory that
that that'll you know make everything
better because the only problem
according to the left according to the
guy we just saw on YouTube the only
problem for most people is just that
they don't have a home and you give them
a home and all everything is better
well let's see how that's going
issues at hotels that are under the
state's homeless Voucher Program are
causing concern in some communities
according to DCF there are 927
households still taking part in that
program Rutland County has the biggest
slice of that number with 236 households
our Ike Ben David joined the tour of a
hotel in Rutland County which officials
say has been causing problems
Brett dezan lives in the Cortina Inn on
a state-funded voucher it's been a
concern for the local community not good
hectic yes hey
crazy too crazy the drugs is out of
control Tuesday afternoon local and
state officials from Rutland County
toured the Cortina to see the issues up
close the hotel is just off of Route 7
which currently has 130 rooms that use
the vouchers on the state's hotel
voucher program it's
depressing you can smell the
the thesis smell that's where the whole
place smelled it doors all around the
property were unlocked and open
so uh there are species all over the
place according to the police chief
everyone's on drugs homeless are leaving
the hotel to Rob nearby businesses
hearing all that you might come to
conclusion that the problem facing all
these homeless people was not in fact
their lack of a home after all the
enlightened residents of Rutland Vermont
uh have removed the variable of
homelessness here and yet these people
are behaving in exactly the same way
they did without a home
we gave them a home and the problem
didn't go away
it's almost like the homeless person's
problem isn't that he doesn't have a
home
now is this an outlier is this an
aberration that only occurs in Rutland
County Vermont let's see the mayor of
Casper Wyoming is currently in full-on
panic mode because roughly 200 people
who have been living in a vacant hotel
in a city have managed to trash the
motel in addition to leaving 500 pounds
of feces on the streets and the
sidewalks quote it's like nothing I've
ever seen before it's third world
country stuff happening in Casper
Wyoming that's according to the mayor
now I don't know how how the mayor came
up with an exact estimate of the
cumulative weight of human fecal matter
and frankly I don't want to know but the
point is that the homeless moved into
town and completely destroyed it they
had access to a vacant Motel to housing
and they proceeded to demolish it and
make it unlivable
again this is a repeatable scenario I'm
not cherry picking it's happening
everywhere that homeless people find a
place to stay
the Los Angeles times recently reported
that a hotel called the Mayfair
sustained 11.5 million damages while it
was being used by the city to house
homeless people as part of something
called project room key quote Windows of
the 294 room Boutique Boutique Hotel in
LA's West Lake neighborhood had been
shattered bathrooms had been vandalized
in some locations carpet had been torn
off the floor
I mean why would you go in the hotel and
tear the carpet off the floor
well I'll tell you why you do that if
you're psychotic or or on drugs that's
why you do it
emails obtained by the Los Angeles Times
show that social workers assigned to the
hotel reported that homeless people were
threatening the staff they were
assaulting people and so on
instead of recognizing what a disaster
this whole idea was Los Angeles
politicians including the mayor want to
double down on it they want to buy the
Mayfair outright and do it all over
again
the only time spoke to one resident who
lives across from the hotel for his
thoughts on the idea and here's what he
said quote the neighborhood is still
recovering from Project room key the
purchase of the Mayfair would be just
completely destroyed the community once
again
that's a reasonable concern because it
happens everywhere that homeless people
are put in hotels during covid the
Lucerne Hotel in New York city became a
shelter for the homeless and what
happened next well according to NBC News
uh quote many on the upper west side
said that their quality of life had been
suffering as a result complaining about
having to walk by people passed out on
sidewalks and Performing lewd acts along
the street
now I could go on because there are many
many places where they have tried this
but you get the idea it always works
this way now to be clear I'm not looking
to just dump on the homeless or mock
them these people are clearly suffering
they are in an unenviable situation no
matter how you slice it but we have to
be honest about what they're suffering
from exactly
and we have to be honest that one way or
another whether it's because of
addiction or psychosis or character
flaws or anything else they're almost
always homeless due to their own
behavior their own choices
these choices of behavior need to change
and if there's a burgeoning epidemic of
homelessness and this and there is then
the real crisis is that so many
Americans have fallen into these
self-destructive patterns of behavior
we can't solve the Homeless Problem
without acknowledging that politically
correct terms like unhoused are meant to
downplay you know a homeless person's
own role in their own homelessness
homelessness but that is the exact
opposite of what we should be doing
ultimately this becomes a conversation
about the crisis of Despair in our
culture that has led to uh so many
people is simply giving up on leading
whole and productive lives
unless we have that conversation as
we've seen in Vermont in Los Angeles New
York and Wyoming and all over the
country
the problem will only get much more
expensive and much worse
this is societal decay
and it is a choice
and ultimately productive members of
society people who would never dream of
doing hard drugs or relieving themselves
in public or committing lewd acts in
public they are the ones who will bear
the cost of that choice
which is why the people who insist on
being politically correct about the
Homeless Problem rather than just being
correct about it are today
canceled if you'd like to see what else
I have to say you can access my full
show by going to dailywire.com or by
going to the Matt Walsh Show Twitter
page hope to see you there Godspeed